element hundred and ten is damn startin
and damn startin is named after the
German town of damn start which is where
the big German accelerator the so-called
gesellschaft which fear ye own fortune
the Society for heavy iron research is
situated and this is because Dom
sturgeon doesn't occur naturally and has
to be made so as element 110 you have to
have the nucleus of the atom actually
having the right number of protons to be
110 so it's 110 protons so the way they
do it is that they take a lamp of lead
and no idea how big and far at it at
enormous speed ions from nickel lead is
element number 82 nickel is element
number 28 28 plus 82 adds up to 110 so
the idea is that these nickel atoms bang
away all the time of the LED and most of
the time everything flies to pieces but
one collision every hundred thousand
million the two nuclei confused together
and for a short time form the element
and so element hundred and ten was
formed in this way and only a few atoms
have ever been observed the the the
nucleus of the of the atom is
electrically charged and so they have an
accelerator which contains negatively
charged plates which accelerates these
things up to close to the speed of light
so their enormous Li energetic it's like
propelling a cricket ball at fantastic
speeds so they have a huge amount of
energy because if you imagine it the two
nuclei are both positively charged you
need an awful lot of energy to get these
to go together it's like banging
together two magnets which have the same
polarity you can't really push them
together easily they tend to repel
but if you push them harder
poom